في مستجدات الملف النووي الايراني اكد
وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد
اللهيان احراز تقدم في المفاوضات وان هناك
جهودا دوليه تبذل من اجل توصل لوثيقه
اتفاق اوليه كما اعرب عبد الله عن امله في
ان يتم التوصل الى نقاط ايجابيه في
المفاوضات بشان الاتفاق النبوي
الاتفاق النووي بايجابياته وسلبياته هو
اليوم وثيقه دوليه وخارطه طريق نحو الغاء
العقوبات نحن في الجهاز الدبلوماسي امامنا
اليوم هذه الوثيقه لرفع العقوبات ولاسابيع
تبادلنا الرسائل ولا يزال تبادل الرسائل
متواصلا فضلا عن جهود وزراء خارجيه
ومسؤوليه بعض الدول لتغيير ما يتم التفاوض
عليه بهدف الوصول الى الاتفاق النهائي
سنواصل التفاوض مع احترام خطوطنا الحمراء
بهدف التوصل الى رفع عقوبات عن البلاد